[Music]
all right what's up guys
mkbhd here
so remember when i asked you a couple
couple weeks ago to vote for
creator of the decade by the shorty
awards
well that did happen uh so it was
awesome enough to be a finalist
in a ridiculous category like that but
of course since i'm in the same category
as casey neistat liza koshy jenna
marbles superwoman and rhett and link i
obviously did not expect to win
but then this happened the creator of
the decade award goes to
mkbhd
[Applause]
[Music]
wow uh so i'm gonna cut that off because
i didn't have much of an acceptance
speech i didn't expect obviously to be
standing up there but i figured i could
use this as a sort of a window to uh now
that i've actually had a second to think
about it what i would have said so i
don't know if you remember last year at
the shorty awards again i was a nominee
and a finalist for the youtuber of the
year category for 2017. and that was
really exciting i always considered
myself a youtuber it was an awesome year
but the word creator
there's so many different creators on so
many different platforms and so many
different formats and of course a decade
a massive amount of time for the last 10
years of videos so there are obviously
so many other different creators that
could have been honored here that
probably should be because they've been
making videos for longer than the 10
years that i have
so this is not something i take for
granted at all i'm super humbled to even
be considered for it um but this is
really special so flashback to saturday
night the night before the shorties
actually i was actually at a different
event a different gala i was honored by
my school stevens tech
with an alumni achievement award
alongside a bunch of other awesome
engineers and business people
and even the cio of spacex went to my
school he was honored there as well so
that was really exciting
and when they talked about what i do for
my award they kind of called it new
media which actually really stuck with
me i think it has a couple different
names you could call it social media or
new media but it all kind of ties in
with this slow rise
versus you know old media which you
might call traditional media but in my
last 10 years on this platform i can
speak to what i've seen in the tech
youtube community because that's what
i'm most a part of
which has been its formation a long time
ago to it developing its own voice
developing its own style both in voices
and actual production
and then creating its own immense value
tech youtubers went from like an
afterthought to their own fun little
niche community to you know some
websites deciding maybe they should make
a youtube channel all the way up to
becoming a staple in what you might call
new media and so there's tech youtubers
covering google samsung and apple events
covering ces covering trade shows
being a huge part of this new wave of
new media doing big time interviews and
collabs and it's all just getting
started so for me this all started as a
kid in a bedroom talking to a camera
about tech
because it's fun as hell and i love tech
but to watch the evolution of not only
just the videos we make but the
community and everything we do here over
the last 10 years to become what it is
today is not only really humbling and
inspiring but
super exciting for the next 10 years so
to all the creators
thank you for doing what you do keep
doing what you're doing don't let anyone
tell you to stop
thank you for watching the videos i make
and uh here's to the next 10 years
thanks for watching
peace
[Music]
oh
[Music]